good morning to all of you we start with
this Alabama is ready to outlaw
virtually all abortions in an effort to
get the Supreme Court to reverse
protections for abortion rights
nationwide the state Senate voted 25 to
6 last night for a bill that already
passed the House overwhelmingly the bill
has no exceptions for victims of rape or
incest
it calls for doctors to be prosecuted
for any abortion related acts except to
save a mother's left a mother's life
rather Jericka Duncan is at the State
Capitol in Montgomery with this next
step in a series of challenges to Roe
vs. Wade
Jericka good morning to you good morning
to you this is a huge win for
anti-abortion activists the bill will
now go to Republican Governor K Ivy's
death she is expected to sign it but
opponents are gearing up for a fight
fighting this legislation they say that
will happen in court
House bill 314 passes in a late-night
vote Alabama got one step closer to
banning nearly all abortions the bill
makes performing an abortion a Class A
felony doctors would face up to 99 years
or life in prison
unlike measures in other states it would
not punish women receiving abortions
this bill to me appears to be about
control
democratic state senator Linda Coleman
Madison is one of only four women in the
35 member Senate all 27 Republicans are
men you never been pregnant it's the
choice of two people in the strong but
it seems like only one is being thrown
under the bus here chaos erupted in a
state Senate last week over an amendment
that would have made abortions legal and
rape and incest cases the exception did
not pass last night this is just a shame
this is a disgrace so far six states
have passed fetal heartbeat bills
banning abortions after six weeks before
a woman may even know she's pregnant
similar legislation has been introduced
in at least 10 others the Alabama bill's
sponsor says it was designed to be
contested and ultimately make its way to
the now conservative-leaning Supreme
Court we can't get
meat meal until we get Roe vs. Wade
revisited and turned over but Democrats
argued the Alabama bill will
disproportionately endanger poor and
minority women who already lack access
to health care only half the state's 67
counties have an obstetrician or doctor
who specializes in pregnancy mia Raven
works with one of the three abortion
clinics left in Alabama why should
people care about this issue men and
women it affects more people than you
knows the problem in the south is we
just don't talk about it if Governor Ivy
signs this bill into law in theory it
would take effect in the next six months
but you have groups like Planned
Parenthood and the ACLU who are
promising to challenge this band
potentially bringing this debate back to
the Supreme Court
Norah all right Jericka thank you this
will continue